Most new ideas are bad.
There’s a reasonpeople haven’t done it before.
Just like most mutations are
evolutionary deadends.
The thing about capitalism is
that it is an emergent system.
Like allevolutionary mechanisms,
powered by mutations.
And in this case, what the
mutations are
are very weird people
trying new stuff.
And when we need really big
progress, big new stuff,
that means we need really, really weird people.
I'm not saying thatevery weirdo has
a brilliant apocalypse-averting idea
that also happens to be
a viable commercialenterprise.
The way forward is to figure out what the public
and private sector can each do best
andhelp them figure out how to stay in their lane.
Weirdos trying stuff and sometimes
being allowedto fail at it
are our best hope as a species.